l'histoire a éclaté au grand jour il y a
une semaine et il a mis un peu de temps
avant de décoller mais là il suscite le
débat et la réflexion de quoi on parle
on parle de la décision de la ministre
Caroline proud d'annuler un événement
organisé par un groupe pro vie donc
anti-avortement à la fin du mois au
Centre des congrès de Québec madame Pro
A invoquer les valeurs québécoises pro
choix donc pro avortement et le fait que
l'événement se tenait dans une société
d'État pour ordonner son annulation
c'était dans une société d'État qui
relève du gouvernement on a des valeurs
on demande donc l'annulation de cet
événement la décision a été applaudi à
l'unanimité c'est rare à l'Assemblée
nationale mais là c'est un mariné un peu
des chroniqueurs se sont demandés s'il
ne s'agit pas d'une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression ce qui soulève la
question suivante quels sont les
critères du gouvernement pour juger si
un événement contrevient ou non aux
valeurs québécoises alors hier la
ministre responsable des conditions
féminines martine Biron madame Biron
c'est fait poser la question on va
écouter sa réponse et garder un œil sur
son attaché de presse à droite de
l'écran parce qu'elle a toutefois elle
intervient pour mettre fin à la
conversation on écoute
il y a pas des risques de dérive avec
cette posture arbitraire là
expliquez-moi votre question mais vous
dites
vous la qualifiez
comme ça avec vous monsieur je pense que
c'est une décision qui a été prise à la
lumière des valeurs de notre
gouvernement
[Musique]
gouvernement kakis qui qui combat la
culture de l'annulation qui qui appelle
qui dit que Gabriel nado Dubois c'est un
wok imaginez demain matin si par exemple
quand par cas quelqu'un veut faire un
congrès un rassemblement contre la loi
96 contre la loi 21 et qui décide
tout le monde a le droit de manifester
dans les Russes que ce que le
gouvernement dit c'est vous tiendrez pas
votre événement dans nos murs mais vous
pouvez le tenir n'importe où ailleurs
dans un organisme privé et là par
exemple mais premièrement les murs sont
les murs qui appartiennent au
contribuables québécois et il y a des
Québécois qui sont produits qui a des
Québécois qui sont trop choix il y a des
religions des Québécois qui sont
religieux il y a des Québécois qui sont
athées je pense que c'est vraiment mais
vraiment aller trop loin et je dois
saluer Michel CEG qui était le premier
chroniqueur à écrire là-dessus parce que
la tendance qui partait c'est tout le
monde applaudissait parce que c'est la
nouvelle façon de faire tout le monde
disait ben c'est normal les valeurs du
Québec mais c'est qui qui décide que à
l'unanimité 8008 millions de Québécois
ont exactement la même opinion Michel et
c'est quoi et c'est quoi le cas par cas
il faut distinguer être trop choix ou le
débat sur l'avortement puis je pense
qu'il faut reconnaître que ça a été une
lutte de très longue à laine pour
laquelle il y a encore des fragilités
pour laquelle on peut encore se
permettre de s'inquiéter si ce droit là
à l'avortement est encore bien protégé
ça c'est une chose ce dont il est
question ici c'est un gouvernement qui
décide soit disant pour protéger les
valeurs québécoises qu'un événement
n'aura pas lieu là on s'attaque
directement à la Charte des droits et
libertés à la liberté d'expression à la
liberté d'opinion à la liberté de
conscience et aussi à la liberté de se
réunir et et le gouvernement à ce
moment-là va devoir nous dire quels sont
les événements permis lesquels ont les
arguments sont pas permis mais moi ce
que ça
et absolument est-ce que ça dit aussi
c'est que dans nos murs pas droit à la
dissidence si vous ne pensez pas comme
le gouvernement ben je regrette vous on
vous permet pas de venir exprimer ça et
et d'une très haut raisons le même
centre des congrès a reçu un événement
pas longtemps avant je crois de l'évêché
de Québec bon les végétaux Québec c'est
la religion catholique la religion
catholique est contre l'avortement
pourquoi c'est permis pour les déchets
de Québec puis pas permis pour cette
organisme qui nous vient d'ailleurs soit
dit en passant alors c'est là où on
banalise et on écarte du revers de la
main cette Charte des droits et libertés
si c'est le cas qu'on nous le dise
clairement qu'on nous dise clairement
dans quelles circonstances pour quel
événement et quand on nous dit on va
décider sur du cas par cas oui mais sous
quel critère là ça devient complètement
de l'arbitraire et et et et honnêtement
dans une démocratie et une scène dém
faut qu'on soit capable d'avoir des
opinions divergentes ça ne veut pas dire
que tout à coup cette protection de
l'avortement ne sera pas préservée parce
que si il y avait lieu et ce matin je
partageais les ondes avec Emilie Nicolas
qui avait complètement raison si par
exemple l'événement se tient ben il y
aura probablement des manifestations
pour dire eh non non on n'est pas
d'accord les mouvements prochois vont
aussi manifester laissons la société
délibérée entre elles plutôt que le
gouvernement qui de son autorité vient
nous imposer de dire non ça cet
événement là oui c'était vraiment là non
ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant et préoccupant pour la suite
des choses Jean-François
moi j'ai réagi dans la demi-heure
lorsqu'on a eu cette information là et
d'ailleurs je l'ai appris sur mon fil
Twitter parce que ruba Gazal se
félicitait donc de Québec solidaire de
cette décision là et pour moi qui suis
pro droit à l'avortement je considère
une décision dangereuse et absurde parce
que la liberté d'expression la liberté
de réunion je vais vous lire l'article
de la Charte québécoise des droits il
dit toute personne intitulée
fondamentales telles la liberté de
conscience la liberté de religion la
liberté d'opinion la liberté
d'expression la liberté de réunion
pacifique et la liberté d'association
c'est écrit nulle part sauf si la
ministre du Tourisme n'est pas d'accord
sauf si c'est dans un édifice
gouvernemental québécois évidemment que
c'est pas écrit et des critères je
trouve ça je comprends le disons la
première réaction de gens qui sont très
attachés au droit à l'avortement se dit
ben là ils vont pas venir critiquer ça
dans notre palais des ouais ok alors
prends une tisane et pense aux droits
fondamentaux puis le dit bon ben je suis
pas d'accord mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
c'est ça la liberté d'expression la
liberté d'expression on la défend pas
quand c'est facile on la défend quand
c'est difficile puis des critères il y
en a ça existe tu as le droit d'exprimer
ce que tu veux dans une réunion
pacifique si tu ne fais pas d'appel à la
haine et d'appel à la violence on n'a
pas besoin de critères supplémentaires
on n'a pas besoin que le gouvernement
québécois réunisse un conseil général de
la carte pour en discuter ces
critères-là ils existent et si
l'association va en cours ce qui va
sûrement faire parce qu'il y avait donné
un délai jusqu'à aujourd'hui au
gouvernement de rétablir la réservation
ben ça va prendre 15 minutes au premier
juge venu qui sait lire les chartes pour
dire qu'ils avaient le droit d'aller là
puis que le gouvernement est en tort
alors donc le gouvernement ce magazine
un échec devant les tribunaux est-ce
qu'un centre de foire peut pas ou un
centre des congrès peut pas refuser
certains clients
le sang peut démontrer qu'il y aura un
appel à la haine où on appelle à la
violence alors c'est la même chose on a
eu le code aux États-Unis de de
pratiquer qui voulaient pas vendre des
gâteaux pour des barrages gays je dis
non c'est tu dois je dis tu peux pas
discriminer dans tes clients en fonction
de quoi que ce soit et des clients la
liberté d'expression et toi tu as raison
d'être c'est de permettre la liberté de
réunion contre rémunération c'est à
raison d'être alors pour moi je suis bon
je suis content de voir que le Parti
québécois qui avait d'abord dans un
premier temps appuyer ça vendredi il y
aurait réfléchi puis maintenant dit ben
non ça se peut pas c'est le fardeau de
la preuve et sur le gouvernement de nous
dire quels sont les critères mais moi je
vais plus loin que ça puis je dis ben
arrêtons de trouver une justification
vous avez présentement en ordre une
libéral un paquiste et un conservateur
qui disent qu'ils sont trop choix en
passant tous les trois et qui disent
quel stupide décision
ok uneanimité sur le panel ici
et moi
le petit pas que je vais faire de plus
puis
le soir du 3 octobre j'ai quand j'ai vu
les résultats d'élection je me suis dit
c'est vers ça qu'on se dirige
c'est-à-dire un gouvernement
majoritairement très fort qui va avoir
une très forte tendance à vouloir tout
contrôler
et ça aussi ça va tout à fait à
l'encontre d'une démocratie et oui je
salue le fait que et Québec Solidaire
est particulier un peu sur leur position
mais ça démontre à quel point dans un
circonstances électoral comme celle-là
faut avoir des oppositions très fortes
malheureusement pas tout à fait le cas
pas tout à fait d'accord
parce que le débat sur l'avortement est
un débat émotif et la lutte a été
pénible la lutte interdit je comprends
ça mais on ne peut pas se soucier et se
distancer de cette façon aussi abrupte
d'une Charte des droits et libertés qui
devrait être notre fierté aussi alors je
dis et le rôle de l'opposition mais
c'est d'être le chien de garde et c'est
d'être capable de réagir fortement à ce
genre de situation
je ne serai pas surpris si demain matin
je ne serai pas surpris si demain
pendant la période des questions Gabriel
Nadaud Dubois va accuser François
Legault d'être un wok
[Rires]
envoyer le qualificatif ok
Jean-François oui alors moi j'ai mon
information c'est que cette décision ne
fait pas l'unanimité au sein de la CAQ
et qui a une personne qui
est très attaché à la liberté
d'expression qui a exprimé sa dissidence
c'est Youri Chassain vous pourrez
peut-être essayer de l'interviewer dans
les corridors ça va être intéressant
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI